it is great to be joined today by Simon
goshawk who's a professor of sociology
at the University of Nevada Las Vegas
his latest book the terminal self looks
at how our activities online at the
terminal transform us he's also author
of a very interesting article called the
infantilization of Western culture which
is going to be the subject matter today
Simon thank you so much for talking to
me thanks for having me so I'm very
interested in this topic of the
infantilization of Western culture
because very often when you hear such
claims made they often are associated
with sort of libertarian beliefs which
often say that the government has sort
of become a nanny state that is too
involved in making sure no one does
anything that might induce self harm of
any kind but when you talk about the
infantilization of Western culture it's
not a libertarian critique at all is it
know a little bit about your critique on
that line yeah well I think that the
institutions in which we participate in
everyday life fail to treat us as adults
so think for example about education I
think about the workplace or think about
the mass media it seems that in many of
those institutions we are treated as
disobedient children who constantly need
to be surveilled they need to be tested
and need to be measured and need to be
controlled as a simple example because
of course I'm connecting the argument of
infantilization to our activities at the
terminal but for example today we have
we are completely denied the right to
privacy so whenever we go online
whenever we click on anything all kinds
of informations are being recorded about
us even in the private sphere even at
home and it seems to me that the right
to privacy is a fundamental adult right
but we've all somehow surrender to the
fact that we have no longer privacy
whatever we do can be observed can be
recorded and that someone may be used
against us and that to me is just one
example of how
our activities at the terminal encourage
a sort of infantile and submissive
attitude rather than an adult one so
let's go through a few examples of that
I mean would you say that any instances
of privacy being exchanged for the
possibility or the perception for
example of security do those also
counted as instances of infantilization
so for example airport security where we
are effectively agreeing if we travel
that TSA gets to look through our stuff
and maybe even you know put us through
one of those porno scanners as I call
them is that would that count as
infantilization even if it is under the
guise of security no I think that if
it's in the guise of security if it's
really justified under the guise of
security but no I would say that bad
form of surveillance is acceptable but
I'm thinking about just everyday
activities you know looking for a movie
or reading a newspaper or connecting
with someone or going online to find a
location for a place meaning whatever we
do at the terminal is being recorded and
constitute an invasion of privacy for no
good reason
when we forget that there was a time not
too long ago and this is a time when I
grew up where all those activities would
leave no trace meaning there was no
record of whether you would read a
newspaper or look at a map or check a
movie or consult a particular website I
mean there was a time where all those
activities were not recorded and we're
not leaving any trace there were not
endangering your privacy and today
whatever we do I determine you know in
dangers the sense of privacy it is for
example very well known that even if
your system is turned off it can still
transmit information about where you are
and what you're doing this is why my
exact even Mark Zuckerberg has placed a
posted on the eye of his laptop camera
so all our devices even in the private
sphere all our devices can be activated
remotely to collect information about us
our conversations can be listened to or
emails can be captured and I don't see
any good reason as to why we have to
submit to that very infantilizing regime
so surveillance we've talked about as an
infantilizing force in culture can you
give us a couple of other examples of
infantilization yes please just watch
your local news I mean you know I watch
the local news here in Las Vegas but
I've lived in other places in the United
States and in contrast to the news which
are being broadcast in other societies
where I live I think that we were being
talked down as if we were a little
[ __ ] children the news are being
given to us in in you know bite sized
completely you know in in particular
packages that don't really mean anything
that don't go into any depth that are
supposed to entertain us news is not
entertainment news is serious business
and so that's another example of how I
think that the mass media politicians
are talking down to us as if we were
[ __ ] children rather than
approaching us as adults were capable of
understanding complex arguments so what
you mentioned entertainment I'm
interested in this when it comes to
entertainment how can we distinguish
between infantilized adults and adults
that are having fun in a way that is not
detrimental so like a sporting event I
think would be an example like I'm from
Argentina soccer is huge in Argentina
and I sometimes I'm able to sort of
intuitively distinguish between someone
who seems to be a little bit too into it
as an adult in a way that seems to start
to separate from sort of just like the
culture and tradition of it and just
adults who seem well-adjusted and are
enjoying it can you talk about that a
little bit when it comes to adults and
entertainment well no I think it is
perfectly okay for adults to engage in
activities that you know are playful and
actually it's very healthy for adults to
engage and
collectivities but what I'm concerned
about is more of an ideology that seems
to consider us as little children that
need to be entertained either by
mind-numbing spectacles or even more
toys I mean you know get some statistics
on that the amount of money that the
adults today are spending on toys on
unnecessary objects that are just making
life a little bit more amusing or more
entertaining or more convenient it is
absolutely astronomical if you look at
the increase of the amount of money
spent for example between the 1950s and
today it's it's absolutely monumental
how much money we spend in order to just
entertain ourselves and I think also
that the forms of entertainment are
infantilizing because in here again I'm
especially concerned by our activities
at the terminal again when we use our
terminal
we are immersing ourselves in a very
self-contained word that is very
personalized this is one of the magic of
the terminal like no other technology we
can personalize our terminal to our
specifications and to our test and tour
personality so that when we turn towards
the terminal we are engulfed into a
particular world where there is very
self-centered that is one and where we
feel very self sufficient because
whatever we like is there in front of us
and whatever we do not like has been
eliminated from the terminal but that's
a very infantilizing way of approaching
life if you will because real life is
not specified to our tastes real life
also contains events and people in
opinions that we don't like real life
does not accommodate to our desires real
life does not respond to whatever it is
that we feel like heading right now and
you know when I hear you saying that
what I actually now am realizing that
there are very similar arguments made
against the sort of safe space trigger
warning status quo that has surfaced in
some college campuses now I want to be
really clear because I'm you may not
know my view on this Simon and
in the audience it's good to restate it
I don't believe that the college campus
safe space trigger warning phenomenon is
as widespread as some people believe it
to be but to the extent that it exists I
do find it problematic and I find it
problematic for the reasons you're
stating which is that it doesn't seem to
do any favors to students in that it
doesn't prepare them for the way that
the world seems to work absolutely
absolutely I really agree that real life
is going to be populated by individuals
who are ferociously against your
opinions and who are going to say things
that will make you uncomfortable and so
it doesn't do anybody any good to cocoon
if you will young adults individuals who
are about to enter the real world in the
marketplace it doesn't do anybody any
good to protect them so much I mean
actually I think that university
education is precisely among other
things besides studying your particular
discipline it's also about preparing you
intellectually and emotionally to face a
word that again does not accommodate to
your tastes and does not accommodate to
your idea isn't that will challenge you
and we're doing a great disservice I
think to the current generation of
students on campuses where we are
insisting that this should not be
exposed to uncomfortable information now
in the article you talked a little bit
about the connection between this sort
of infantilization and infantile
thinking and authoritarian rule and I'd
be interested in hearing you talk a
little bit about how you believe that
connection exists well because there's a
very interesting book called consumed by
a Benjamin barber and he suggests the
Emme sees the rise of what he calls an
infantile East ethos anything that this
particular way of thinking favors fast
over slow simple over complex and more
rather than less
and of course politicians who explain
complex arguments by following this
particular logic logic file solution
rather than long one or simple
explanations rather than complicated
ones of course the tap into a particular
infantile craving if you will that the
word should be fast and easy and morally
you know more gadgets or more toys or
whatever and so politicians were going
to use that particular philosophy or
that particular approach nurture those
infantile tendencies and I think that in
a society in a world as complex as the
one in which we live it would be
completely foolish and delusional to
believe that there are simple and fast
solutions to anything but but stunningly
I mean that there is I believe that in
the United States one of the reasons
that the Republican Party has been as
successful as it has been is that they
do provide simple neatly packaged
explanations or positions I mean
taxation is like a prototypical example
if you are on the right and you say hey
it's your money taxes should be as low
as possible it's extraordinarily simple
it's extraordinarily concise and the the
left doesn't have an opposite they don't
say we just want taxes as high as
possible they immediately launch into
nuance which I believe is of course
necessary nuance but you're already sort
of losing when you can't simplify the
argument yes unless we have a more
educated population that understands
right right you know those those quick
and fast and simple arguments make us
feel good but they really don't resolve
anything but in order for those kinds of
arguments to to to penetrate we need a
population that does not surrender to
those infantile impulses to those
infantile desires to be provided with
simple and fast solutions by
authoritarian father figures and what
are some of the ways that society could
be molded in that sense I mean I think
not teaching critical thinking starting
in middle school is a problem but it
might be naive to think that if you
start teaching critical thinking when
kids are 12 that it solves the problem
it seems that there's much more to it
yeah because the education institution
is just one node if you will of that
infantile ization recommends media is
also infantilizing the workplace is also
infantilizing but i think that you know
starting to educate children early on
into critical thinking would already
produce different kinds of citizens how
is it that you know the societies they
manage to do it in the manage to do it
very well right for example Finland is
is very frequently cited as one of the
countries where that scores the highest
on happiness and well-being people are
extremely happy in Finland people are
typically very healthy and the Finland
is probably the society with the best
education and it's also a very taxed
country that's a people in Finland are
very heavily taxed but they don't see
any problem with it right so I mean as
an educator I believe that education is
in a one particular place where I see
the infantilization of the population
even in academia and I mean you know I'm
not an expert on you know on the economy
or I'm not an expert on the political
institution but you know as someone who
works in the education institution I can
see where we can make tremendous
progress not in inculcating children
into any ideology and they're interested
in brainwashing you know students into
voting right or voting land but think
that it's very important to teach
children and young adult our of critical
thinking the power of being able to
examine arguments logically rather than
responding viscerally to what makes us
feel good the article is the
infantilization of Western culture we've
been speaking with the article's author
Simon goshawk who's a professor of
sociology at the University of Nevada
Las Vegas Simon really a pleasure
speaking with you today I appreciate it
my pleasure